en Roumanie on préfère donner dans le
surréalisme quand chaochescou par
exemple justifie à la télévision la
répression féroce du weekend dernier ou
quand chaochescou ce matin condamne
l'intervention militaire américaine au
Panama la situation semble beaucoup
moins assuré pour le génie des Carpates
comme il se fait appeler ce matin en
effet de nouvelles manifestations
auraient eu lieu à Timisoara malgré les
les victimes du weekend dernier par
ailleurs certaines sources font
maintenant état d'un ralliment de
certaines unité de l'armée au
manifestants Patricia Coste l'état
d'urgence dans l'ouest de la Roumanie a
été décrété hier soir par
nicolaouescu les forces armées les
troupes de police ainsi que la milice
sont passé en état d'alerte le décret
pris par celui qu'on appelle kandukator
prohibbe également tout déplacement ou
rassemblement de plus de 5 personnes
cheouesku est décidé à se battre
jusqu'au bout ce matin lors d'un
rassemblement à Budapest il a donné le
ton je souhaite une action ferme contre
les agissements qui tente de détruire
l'indépendance et le socialisme en
Roumanie le mot à retenir est
l'indépendance du pays c'est contre les
menaces qui viendrait de Hongrie que
touesku compte pouvoir encore
mobiliser il poursuit organisé dans
toutes les entreprises partout des
troupes pour assurer l'ordre pour
défendre le socialisme pour défendre
tout ce à quoi nous tenons
l'indépendance du pays nous agissons au
service du peuple au service du
socialisme
mais on vient d'apprendre que lors de
cette manifestation officielle des
manifestants ont crié des slogans contre
che le discours radio télévisé a été
interrompu au bout de 3 minutes et des
manifestants ont ensuite défilé dans les
rues de Budapest en criant
AB ce témoignage provient d'un diplomate
qui a requis l'anonymat ce diplomate a
ajouté avoir entendu une forte explosion
il y a 1 heure à
Budapest